related machine exactly thanks to the
organizers for inviting me
so I'll talk about if my yeah so I'll
talk about what's a fairly strict simple
problem so there are a bunch of jobs
every job has a size and I want to
schedule these jobs on machines every
machine has a certain speed so for
example if I schedule the first job on
the first machine it takes 1.1 units of
time to complete so I schedule the
second job which is much longer on the
second machine which is much faster
again the running time of that job on
the machine is the ratio of its size and
the speed so I want to schedule these
jobs in a way that the total loads so
the load of a machine is simply the
total time for which the machine runs
and I want to optimize some function of
these loads so once I have scheduled all
the jobs you get a certain load on every
machine I want to optimize certain sum
function of these loads now in this talk
the problem the problem we are looking
at is an online problem which means that
when I'm scheduling a particular job I
don't see anything in the future ok so I
only see one job I know what I've done
till now I need to schedule the job and
therefore I would be looking at the
competitive ratio of these Oktay
algorithm which is simply the ratio
between what whatever objective the
algorithm produces to whatever is the
optimal objective and the optimal could
be offline it's just absolute octave ok
so that's the problem so there's one
thing I haven't specified yet which is
the function that I want to optimize so
what are natural functions so again I
have this vector of loads after I've
made all the assignments this is the
vector over the machines what do I want
to optimize maybe one simple thing one
might want to optimize is just a total
amount of processing I do the total time
for which machines run this is just a
one norm of the load this is very simple
to do I can assign all my jobs to the
fastest machine this will optimize this
norm now the bad thing about this now of
course is that it doesn't do any kind of
load balancing that I have a lot of
machines I'm just using one of them so
one could go to the other extreme and
one could try to optimize the mix
which is the infinity norm of the lotor
I want to simply optimize the maximum
load and in general one would probably
want to optimize some some balance
between one would want to achieve some
balance between these two kinds of
objectives one that optimizes the total
amount of processing the other that
optimizes the maximum processing on a
single machine so one can look at any
arbitrary norm any arbitrary what's
usually called a LP or P norm I'll call
it a q norm or NQ norm just so that I
don't confuse with peas which are which
for me are our processing times of jobs
so that's what I want to optimize I want
to optimize arbitrary q norms for this
problem so this is what I want to do q
norms and related machines what's known
so this problem of course it's not known
that's why I'm standing here talking
about it but if you want to optimize the
makespan then there are well-known
algorithms to do it in fact the
algorithm we will look at look at one
such algorithm this algorithms are
usually called the slow fit or slowest
fit algorithms so we'll look at it soon
and of course a lot more is known if I
either generalize the problem or
specialize it so either I can generalize
the problem to what's called unrelated
machines in which case the running time
of a job on different machines are
completely uncorrelated in that case the
exact picture is don't we all of these
all these competitive ratios that I have
quoted are tight and if I specialize it
to identical machines if all my machines
have the same speed again the exact
picture is known okay so we know
constant competitive algorithms in one
case we know in the other case that
constant algorithms can scons and
competitive ratios are not possible okay
so what's the situation for related
machines that's what I want to address
today now before I go there I want to
make one remark so one thing you might
guess from looking at this slide is that
perhaps constant competitive makespan
algorithms imply constant competitive
algorithms for for all norms but there
is a qualitative difference between
identical machines and related machines
are the kind of problem that I am
looking
so in identical machines there you don't
need to know what norm you are
optimizing you can make an assignment of
jobs you can come up with a schedule
that's good for every norm okay I can
state the norm after the fact and it
would be good it would be constant
comparative for that now
this is ruled out for related machines
this is not possible which means that
this algorithm that gives me a good
makespan bound is essentially useless
for any other norm and we are going to
see I mean it's also this the fact that
this algorithm does not extend is deeper
and we'll see technical reasons why it
does not but even at a superficial level
it is enforced it is impossible that a
single algorithm that does not know what
the norm is can come up with a schedule
that's good for all norms unlike in the
case of identical machines that's clear
from even one and infinite yeah all
right so the main result that I am going
to talk about is indeed there exists a
constant competitive algorithm for
scheduling jobs on related machines and
and this will as I just stated this
algorithm will be cognizant of the norm
where I'm trying to optimize so it will
take the norm into account so if you are
optimizing the l2 norm it will use the
fact that you are optimizing it okay so
let's step back and look at what this
makespan minimizing algorithm is the
so-called slow fit algorithm so there
are various versions of this algorithm
that get different constants but here's
a here's a very simple version and in
fact I think this is the first version
that was suggested so just take your job
and assign it to the slowest machine
where if after the assignment the load
on the machine does not exceed two
icesoft
okay and assume for now that you know
the value of op this is this is without
loss of generality to some constant
factor you can guess and double up your
guesses so you know the value of opt you
simply try you're signing on all the
machines the first the slowest one where
you can without blowing up your load too
much that's the one you actually assign
to so of course if this algorithm
succeeds you get a two approximation if
if up was known if you had to guess off
some constant approximation
so the the proof essentially shows that
for this algorithm you would be able to
assign every job okay you don't get
stuck at some point and I won't give you
the proof but it's a it's a very simple
proof now if we try to take this
intuition that we have to assign to
slowest machines subject to this kind of
a criterion how do we take this
intuition and use it even for one norm
let's say which indeed is a easy problem
but how do we use this intuition
unfortunately it's not so clear how do I
even define a slow fit algorithm for any
other norm even if I tell you what the
value of opt is how do you define an
algorithm like this because the value of
opt
only in the case of makespan it tells me
what's going on in every machine if I
just give you a value of R for any other
norm it tells me nothing about what's
happening in individual machines so you
can try simple strategies maybe you take
the value of up the overall contribution
across the machine split it up equally
across the machines and that gives you
some bound on what's going on in each
machine but this is clearly bad so for
instance if I have a lot of slow
machines and I'm only optimizing the one
norm
I'll try assigning to all those slow
machines and at some point clearly I
will have a huge value of the one norm
so there is no reasonable way that we
can take a single value of up and split
it up across machines and and hope to
get a good estimate of what individual
loads on machines are so that's where
the theme of this workshop comes up I
need a better lower bound on the value
of up I need us more structural lower
bound that tells me what's going on on
individual machines and for that what we
are going to use here is is a continuous
relaxation of the problem si where we're
going to solve a continuous relaxation
that will tell me what's going on in
individual machines I'll use that in my
algorithm okay so that's the plan then
my algorithm has two stages of course
it's an online algorithm so these stages
are interleaved but logically there are
two stages I'll first get a fractional
assignment and the fraction we'll think
of the fractional assignment is
assigning tiny epsilon fractions of my
job and then I'll round that algorithm
around the fractional assign
now one thing to notice that so maybe
the most popular kind of algorithm that
gets fractional assignments are these
multiplicative weight algorithms these
are not very useful in this context I
want to get constant competitive
algorithms if you use any kind of
reasonable multiplicative weights
algorithm it doesn't tend it tends to
lose logarithmic factors okay so we are
going to have to design a new new
fractional algorithm for this problem
all right so let's start off with the
fractional algorithm at this point I
only want to get a fractional assignment
so the first thing is how do I realize
what is the objective that I'm trying to
optimize in the fractional case and I
won't go into details of why this is the
right relaxation but this is why this is
the right fractional objective but let
me describe it
so this objective has two terms the
first term is kind of what what you
would normally relax the integral
objective to so it just says that take
the fractional load on every machine
raise it to to the ^ Q can't and just
two in it from this point on in the talk
I am only going to be talking about the
Q raise to Q norm so I'm not going to do
this one one raising the whole thing to
1 1 over Q at the end right this is this
is something I will do as a post
processing step I it doesn't really
matter it keeps things simple to look at
this stuff so that's the first term the
first term is just the total fraction of
load on every machine raised to cube the
second term is maybe a little more
complicated a little different where I
take the Q at norm of every individual
job and then I split it up across the
different machines okay so this is a
linear term second one is a linear term
the first one is is clearly not linear
so I have these two terms I want to
optimize them and and we need these two
terms just one of these terms has pretty
bad integrity gaps and that was known
this is not there's not something new
okay so let me call them FX and GX to
understand the algorithm let's do a
couple of thought experiments the
thought experiments are simple ones what
if I only had one of these two terms if
I didn't have the other one let's first
start off with GX if I only had a linear
term that I wanted to optimize what
should I have done well here the answer
is very simple I should always be
assigning the job to the fastest machine
this this term is lean linear in the
assignment clearly the fastest machine
gives me the smallest coefficient so I
should be assigning there but let me
rewrite that that rule as saying that I
want to assign to the machine that has
the smallest gradient of G X with
respect to X X the assignment variable
the same thing I just wrote it in this
manner because I want to generalize it
later the more complicated one is what
if I only had the first term so one
thing to note is that the first term FX
is a load dependent term it depends on
what I have done in the past second term
does not care it's a linear term so it
only depends on what I am doing with the
current job that I have so for the first
term if you think about it for a minute
you'll see that the best thing that I
can hope to do is keep the derivative
the same across all the machines because
if my derivative becomes unequal in two
machines I can move a little bit of a
job from the higher derivative to the
lower one and that will improve my
overall objective so the right strategy
if I only had the first term is to
somehow keep the derivatives equal which
again you can think of as assigning
incremental e to the machine that gives
me the smallest derivative of the first
term so both these terms individually if
I were trying to optimize I should
really be assigning that infinitesimal
job to the machine that gives me the
smallest derivative and indeed that's
what we do in the actual algorithm so of
course the natural extension of this
these experiments would be to say that I
take the derivative of the sum and
assign it to the one that minimizes this
this by itself is a little cumbersome
and thought to
work with but that's it's in the same
spirit we assign to the one that
minimizes the maximum of these two
derivatives yes it's the same thing of
the sound if that's more convenient it's
easier for the proof if you use the max
okay so that's the entire description of
the fractional algorithm very simple
algorithm how do we analyze this
algorithm just split it up into tiny
fractions and or you can think of it as
a continuous algorithm so that's the
algorithm so let's try to analyze it so
before we analyze it it will be useful
to understand the structure of what's
going on so some structural property so
let us try to map these derivatives of
these two terms F and G against the
speed of the machines so I am drawing
the machines in decreasing speed so how
do the derivatives of the second term
the linear term look in terms of the
machine in inter in terms of machine
speeds so clearly that's a linear term
the derivative just keeps increasing as
my machine speed decreases so this one
is pretty straightforward
the key observation is that if I looked
at the first term the first term is more
tricky its load dependent but if I
looked at the first term I claimed that
my derivatives actually go exactly the
opposite way so throughout the algorithm
my derivatives will keep decreasing with
increasing with decreasing speed so let
me give some into I won't give a formal
proof of this but let me give some
intuition for why this is true so what
was I doing I was taking the max of two
derivatives and I was optimizing for
these for that max if FX if the
derivative of FX was always the max if
it was always bigger than G then I would
keep all the effects as two derivatives
equal right that's what we just argued a
couple of slides back that I should be
keeping all of them equal if FX was
always winning the max then I would
basically not get
CGT at all in my algorithm but FX does
not win the max comparison all the time
sometimes for slower machines G might
win the max comparison what does that do
that forces me to assign my job to
faster machines even though that have a
higher value of the derivative of G wins
the comparison then I always go to a
faster machine so what that means is
that it skews the derivatives on the
first term in exactly the opposite way
of the second term so I have this
picture and I ger if I'm always
maintains this more eternity property
why is this useful well let's look at
two cases so of course where is the
algorithm actually assigning it goes to
the middle there are two curves it goes
to the middle and assigns right there so
if it was continuous it would assign
exactly where at the point where these
two curves cross it's discrete so it
assigns at one of the two neighboring
jobs to neighboring machines okay so how
do we use this so let's look at two
cases the first one is the easier one
where opt actually assigns to a slower
machine here the comparison is obvious I
am assigning at lower derivatives than
opt is ops derivative on the second term
itself is higher so clearly I can charge
what whatever increase I am getting in
my objective to whatever opt is getting
okay so remember G is load independent
the second term is load and depend and
it doesn't matter what ops current state
is it just depends on what opt is doing
with that job the trickier case is if
opt both went to a faster machine so
here it is true that in the algorithm on
that faster machine I have a larger
derivative on F but that's in the
algorithm maybe off was clever and had a
very small derivative on the value of F
on that machine okay so how do we get
around this so here I will cheat a
little bit
it's take my word for it that that that
that this treating is is permitted so
let me assume this cheating is that let
me assume that this this curve on the
derivatives on the first term is true
even if I only consider
jobs of this kind jobs where opt is
going to a faster machine this is not
true in general but losing some constant
factors we can make make this work
okay so imagine that I had this stronger
property that just for these jobs I have
this slope of derivatives on the first
term then I claim life is good for me
why
how does so this is how the algorithm
looks how does opt look can look its
derivatives can be completely
uncorrelated it can be completely
arbitrary however I have a prefix
property here all these jobs software
into faster machines than I did so if I
cut this slope off anywhere then opt has
more jobs to the left than I do so using
this fat I can smooth out ops irregular
curve into something that looks like
this without increasing ops objective so
I can smooth it out to something where
opt has a curve on derivatives that
dominates my curve point wise and the
objective of opt in this smoothing has
not increased so that says now I am fine
because I can now just charge my costs
to ops cost on the same machine so this
was a bit hand wavy but but this is the
basic idea how the proof for the
fractional algorithm works so eventually
this gives us a constant competitive
ratio for the fractional problem but
just this is just a refraction 'el
solution if there are any questions I
can answer about this before I go to
rounding
so let's go to rounding now so I have
this fractional solution how do I round
it make any connection maybe I do I
don't know an explicit connection sort
of like a your objective is a convex
separable function some resource
allocation of it so a fractal problem
she is solving a fashion for me I don't
know if it satisfies the curvature
condition system yeah I mean you have to
go and check the yeah yeah I don't I
mean it's a constant like absolute
constant
okay so how do we round this so let's
say I come up with some fractional
assignment of the job so one very
natural thing to try maybe is to take
the median of so this is fractional
assignment gives me a distribution of
the job across the machines on maybe
natural thing to try is to assign it to
the median of assign the job to the
median of this distribution why is this
good so let's look at again these two
terms FX and GX that I have I claim that
if I always assign to the median then
I'm always good at least on the second
term in this objective why because half
my job has been assigned to slower
machines by my fractional assignment and
the slower machines have a larger value
for GX irrespective of what's happened
without my odd with the other jobs in my
system so as far as GX is concerned I'm
always good if I assign to the median
problem is with FX in general I should
also be good in terms of FX because half
my jobs went to faster machines and I
have some intuition which says that on
faster machines the derivative of FX was
even higher so somehow I should be able
to charge my cost to the faster machines
but just this clearly is not a good
solution for example think of a
situation where the fractional algorithm
simply splits every job equally across a
bunch of machines then this median
rounding will send all the jobs into one
machine in the middle so that's clearly
not a good algorithm
it will do it for an arbitrary saying
like fractional assignment so the
intuition for now is tailored to the
first part but eventually it will do it
for any arbitrary standard okay so so
how do we make this work suppose I am I
really like this idea of assigning to
the median machine which seems to have
some nice properties in the offline
world
I think the algorithms that I'm aware of
don't go through relaxed and round but
but maybe there is some rounding I'm not
I'm not kind of business here okay so so
if I want to stick to this plan of
assigning to the median here's one idea
so maybe let me instead of thinking of
these as individual machines
let me think of each machine as a set of
machines so as I go down this list these
are slower and slower machines but if I
could replace every if I could make sure
that the total speed of the group of
machines at at any of these layers is at
least the sum of speeds of all the
faster machines then I would be in much
better shape because half my machines
were being sent to faster machines and
if I go to the median group the median
group overall has processing power or
sum of speeds that captures all these
faster machines so if I think of these
as machine groups instead of individual
machines and somehow managed an
exponential increase in every step of
the total speed then
maybe some rounding algorithm like this
could work and that's what we try to do
so here's what I want to do I want to
somehow get machine groups such that as
I go down to slower machines the total
speed of the machines the sum of speeds
keeps doubling so I have slower machines
but have many more of them so that any
if I if if half the jobs were being
assigned to faster machines just
assigning them to the median group is
enough
the median group has enough processing
power that covers all the faster
machines but in general and instance may
not have this property maybe all my
processing power is concentrated on high
speed machines in the instance so we use
a general technique which takes an
arbitrary instance and converts it into
an instance that has this property and
we do this readily so the first machine
becomes a group on its own then we keep
going until we collect a total speed
that's double the first group and
replace those machines with machines
that are half the speed of my first
group keep going so again I get a bunch
of machines there the total speed of
this machine should double my previous
group so it's exponentially increasing
in the total speed but then I replace
them by machines that are uniform and be
sure that this and this is a technique
that has nothing to do with the
particular problem at hand you can take
any any scheduling problem with related
machines and convert it you know with
make this transformation of the instance
and be sure that this transformation
only loses a constant for any norm so no
matter which normal I'm trying to
optimize of course the transformation
itself uses the norm so you have to be
careful in how do you do the
transformation you have it must use the
value of the norm but it only lose at a
constant so any any schedule on the
original instance can be mapped to the
translated instance and vice versa so
now I have an instance that looks like
this it's a very nice instance I my
machine speeds keep doubling sorry
machine speeds keep hopping and my total
speed the sum of machine speeds keeps
doubling
so now I rerun my fractional algorithm
but not on these machine groups thinking
of these entire groups as single
machines so the fractional algorithm
only decides which group to send it to
then I use my median rounding that gives
me an integral assignment into a group
but the good thing is that a group now
has machines that look exactly the same
so I can use a post processing on this
which just is an identical machines
algorithm inside the group and that's
the overall algorithm and gives me a
constant so just before I end this is
the last slide this techniques these
techniques also solve more general
problems so for example if instead of
one-dimensional single dimensional loads
I have multi-dimensional loads you have
many different let's say resources and a
job needs multiple resources it also
solves solves the multi-dimensional
erecta scheduling problem and that's all
I have thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the optimization problem was to maximize
that subject to just a constraint that
this self-excited should be won and
they're positive
many more times that's what this is
solving there was basically
there's no I so so the only thing only
issue is that like in my description I I
used an integral optimum but this is
this is this can be changed to the
fractional optimum if you want my
suspicion is that might also be that
might also be a good algorithm but the
analysis becomes Messier and the
analysis is much simpler if I because we
lose these properties this structural
property and then the analysis gets a
bit messy no but I mean I lose this
structural property this this property
is something that's crucial for my
analysis and I lose
and then that this should give you the
fractional engine be simple point five
one five on what 1/2 coffee ratio that's
not that's not obvious to me minimizing
our function the go.you minimizing it oh
yes oh my back yeah
let's thank all the speakers of the day
[Applause]
[Music]